hi i'm eric boss and christopher nolan's
inception boomed us into an existential
crisis that we may never wake up from
leaving us like ellen page in this movie
only able to speak in questions you're
not gonna tell me anything about this
question wait whose subconscious are we
going into exactly
inception explored the nature of reality
with a film structure that reflects the
surreal illusions of its subject matter
and after my recent rewatch and analysis
of the hidden clues to how the matrix
pulled off a similar feat and re-watches
of nolan's dark knight trilogy let us
re-examine inception for all the secrets
that are only now being discovered so
let's strap in hit snooze and uh volume
warning because
you know it's coming
and actually it's appropriate to begin
with that wrong sound effect because
inception opens with hans zimmer's
thunderous score
[Music]
this music is actually a super slowed
down version of edith pf's non-general
gretliane sorry for the bad french
pronunciation this is a song that they
use in the film as a musical countdown
to synchronize the kicks
[Music]
the time dilation of each successive
dream level stretches out the song's
tempo which zimmer reflects in his
orchestration
[Music]
nolan chose this song specifically
because its lyrics explore the effect of
memories on the psyche and how
destructive not letting go of painful
heartbreak can have on one subconscious
in the original french the lyric i
regret neither the good things done to
me nor the bad things is nila bien
komafei ni lamal and that last word maul
translates to some version of bad in
several languages and of course it is
the name of marion cotillard's villain
character a painful memory who aims to
literally destroy this hero's
subconscious ironically before inception
kotiard played edith pioff in levien
rose singing this song in particular one
of the many crazy meta coincidences in
this movie as we'll see inception is
itself designed to feel like a dream
with nolan casting dreams and the dream
building process as an extended metaphor
for films in the filmmaking process
there is actually neurological evidence
that brain activity when you're watching
a movie is very similar to that when
you're sleeping in both cases the visual
cortex is highly active and the
pre-frontal cortex which deals with
logic analysis and self-awareness is
inactive so we see a ton of crazy stuff
but we don't question it writers like
walter merch have explored how our love
of film comes from a natural acclamation
from our dreaming processes and to prove
inception the film is structured like
one of the dreams in the film nolan
actually timed the whole film at exactly
two hours and 28 minutes a dilated
synchronization with the timing of pf's
song which is exactly two minutes and 28
seconds
the opening image shows cobb leonardo
dicaprio on the beach now the name cobb
is a nod to the thief in nolan's earlier
film following and to the american
architect henry encob a combination of
which gives you this cob an architect
building dreams in order to steal the
crashing wave imagery reflects
philosopher carl young's description of
water as a symbol of the subconscious
water by nature deconstructs things yet
it also connects to other water in a
vast shared network the way our
subconscious is a collective ocean of
ideas water crashes in on cobb again and
again in this movie to represent his
collapsing mental state cobb sees these
children who are turned away from him
and we later learned that these are
projections of his children philippa and
james haunting his dreams now they begin
to turn but cobb doesn't see their faces
partly because he can't remember what
they look like but also as we'll see
later he fears that looking at their
faces in his dreams will trap him in
this unreal place forever because
they'll never want to leave cobb gets
taken in to meet an elderly saito can
water who finds cobb's top this is a
totem that cobb uses to determine his
reality if the top spins and spins
forever he's in a dream if it topples
over he's in reality but we also learned
that this top wasn't cobb's totem
originally it was actually mauls cobb
carries it to represent his guilt over
maul and his guilt for how he used this
object to infect her mind also notice
that cobb is wearing a wedding ring here
and we only ever see him wearing that
ring in his dreams and in his flashbacks
where maul is still with him but never
in reality where she's dead so it's
possible that cobb's wedding ring is
actually his original totem by the way
my totem is his dancing baby groot in
reality he gets tired and stops dancing
but in the dream he dances and dances
forever actually
[Music]
all right good we cut from sado to cobb
then back to sado from cobb's point of
view but zado's now decades younger this
transition seamlessly jumps back in time
without any clunky earlier title using
reverse shots to put us inside cobb's
point of view as he suddenly remembers
his earlier dream with sado it's subtle
disorienting the way dreams transition
from moment to moment you'll notice that
dicaprio as the younger cobb is really a
visual doppelganger for the director
christopher nolan probably not a
coincidence if inception the film is a
story about a dream builder trying to
get back to his kids comparing this to
the filmmaking process suggests nolan
sees cobb as a version of himself a
homesick director losing himself in and
out of dream worlds that he creates gig
after gig of extracting riches from
audiences until he finds one last job to
artfully incept meaning into his
audience's minds that will allow him to
see his kids again whether or not you
buy this it's worth pointing out that
the younger version of cobb's son here
is played by magnus nolan christopher
nolan's son cobb's right hand man is
arthur joseph gordon-levitt if cobb is
the writer director of this filmmaking
metaphor arthur is a producer of cobb's
art the one figuring out the nuts and
bolts of the idea to execute the vision
cyto represents the studio head the
financier or the executive producer and
their pitch to him is essentially a
movie pitch with cobb the creative
turning him off with a joke and arthur
the producer rephrasing things cobb
compares ideas to viruses idea resilient
highly contagious it's similar to agent
smith's comparison of the human species
to a virus in the matrix a film that
nolan cited as one of his reference
points along with dark city in the 13th
floor all of which explored the idea of
the world around us not being real
sato's dining room was inspired by the
nijo castle in kyoto japan which is the
city cobb later says he's deboarding the
bullet train at at the head of this
table is the willow chair design of
charles renee mcintosh and the barrel
chair designs of frank lloyd wright
because the architect of this dream nash
probably saw these real-life architects
as inspirations and then cobb finds maul
outside
if i jumped
would i survive
maul is actually taunting him
deliberately reminding cobb of her
suicide nolan designed maul to be the
essence of the femme fatale a character
trope from film noir with maul as a
female antagonist who's the
manifestation of the hero's own neurosis
and fear of how little he knows about
his lover inside maul compliments that
painting it's actually a real work by
francis bacon called study for head of
george dyer bacon was also a huge
influence for nolan inspiring the look
of the joker's face paint in the dark
knight bacon's subject here was his late
lover whom he painted long after dyer's
death to perpetuate his memory just like
how cobb is perpetuating maul's memory
trying to use her in his heist did the
children miss me
i can't imagine cobb's response both
tells us that he has no idea what his
kids are thinking but also they can no
longer literally imagine what his kids
look like because they've aged and that
he can't look at their faces in his
dreams so cobb shoots these guards and
he stealthily catches the bullet casings
before they hit the ground to avoid any
noises to disrupt the dream level and
then back in the dining room cobb opens
the safe which we learn that extractors
design into dreams so that the dreamer
will subconsciously fill it with their
secrets and then notice the last number
on the combination is 53. now repetition
of numbers is key in inception and 2053
is a recurring number for cobb you'll
notice later that it was on the taxi
that they used in the first stream level
20 is also the first number on the
combination on maul's dream safe and
limbo now that number reversed is 3502
which also shows up throughout this
movie it was the room number of the
hotel suite where maul committed suicide
and it's on the train that crashes
through the dream with maul using the
same train from their double suicide in
limbo now destroying cobb's plan so cobb
reversed maul's perception of reality by
tampering with her totem so she gets
back at him by reversing his meaningful
number into a malevolent force now this
standoff and shootout drip with
hollywood cliche guns tuxedos but it is
designed to lean into tropes like this
because every dream level and inception
is intended to feel like an action film
because often that's how we dream nolan
uses these basic common understandings
of dreams as the rules of his world
people typically describe dreams with
elements like waking up when you die in
a dream not knowing that you're dreaming
while you're in the dream experiencing
time more slowly physical forces like
pain gravity noises affecting you in the
dream experiencing dreams within dreams
sensing the essence of people in places
despite them looking physically
different and of course the kick that
odd sensation of falling that muscle
spasms you awake but the one new fantasy
element that nolan introduces to this
world is the technology of shared
dreaming which he even justifies later
if you're listening closely so as the
dream collapses maul tells sado
now i always found this odd because maul
isn't working for sato she's cobb's
chaotic projection she just wants to
screw everything up but then notice her
reaction when sado realized that cops
switched the envelopes she's smiling
maul feels victorious because cobb is
victorious by telling sado that cobb got
close she's bragging to sado talking up
cobb skills for cobb because cop knows
this extraction was a test by sato and
now maul senses that this next gig will
bring cobb even closer to losing himself
to her so nash gives gob the kick dunks
him and sato recognizes that the rug of
this love nest is off realizing that
this is also a dream if you think about
it this rug functions as sado's totem
something that only he knows the precise
nature of to determine if he's dreaming
makes you wonder what he and his
mistress were doing all the time on that
rug attaboy sado so this stream also
collapses revealing that this was a
dream within a dream actually including
the prologue it's a flash forward within
a dream within a dream so that makes
three awakenings for cobb here similarly
the first act of the matrix features
three false awakenings to foreshadow the
hero's ultimate spiritual awakening and
to make us reality paranoid the whole
time so cobb departs saying
i don't like trains another bit of
foreshadowing toward the way he and maul
kill themselves to escape limbo so later
cobb spins the top and lifts the gun
ready to shoot himself if it keeps
spinning showing his fragile mental
state and struggle with reality but you
can see here that cobb is no longer
wearing his wedding ring since in
reality his wife is dead sado asks cobb
and arthur about
deception which arthur says is
impossible giving sado the example don't
think about elephants it's actually a
nod to the title of a book about
cognitive semantics george laykov's
don't think of an elephant which
describes conceptual framing using
specific words to discreetly insert
feelings and ideas into someone's mind
sato offers to clear cobb's criminal
charges so that he can return home to
his kids do you want to take a leap of
faith
or become an old man
filled with regret so these men will
later exchange these same words in limbo
to remember this arrangement but right
now this line jumps out to cobb because
it echoes maul right before her suicide
i'm asking you to take a leap of fame
maybe cobb sees his coincidence as more
evidence that this reality could still
be a dream but either way he takes this
leap of faith with sado to wake himself
up from this nightmare which began when
he couldn't take the leap of faith with
maul in paris cobb meets his
father-in-law miles mike okay an
architecture professor who tells him
come back to reality tom ah just as
michael kaine did in the dark knight he
hints at the thematic lesson that the
hero must learn cobb still believes this
reality is controlled by external
factors but the truth is our reality is
something we choose miles introduces
cobb to a new architect ariadne ellen
page now in the filmmaking metaphor
ariane is a production designer the
artist who conceives the visual
aesthetic and language of the movie the
name ariadne alludes to greek mythology
the princess daughter of king minos who
aided the hero theseus by helping him
navigate the labyrinth and avoid the
minotaur this ariane helps cobb navigate
the labyrinths to escape his maul notar
i'm sorry cobb tests ariana by telling
her to design a maze on the spot and she
succeeds ultimately by ignoring the
graph paper grid thinking literally out
of the box designing this circular maze
which is actually a similar layout to
king minos's labyrinth and lots of
artwork so in various greek myths a maze
represents the journey of one's own
enlightenment and to navigate the maze
is to confront your darkness according
to psychologist marie louise von franz
mazes are symbols of the subconscious
mind with the winding paths and dead
ends reflecting our wandering thoughts
stanley kubrick who perhaps influenced
nolan more than any other filmmaker
adopted this maze concept in his film
the shining in which the hedge maze and
the maze-like hallways of the overlook
hotel paralleled jack's mental state
with his disorientation in that maze
reflecting his insanity nolan's brother
and sister-in-law jonathan nolan and
lisa joy also used this maze conceit
with their show westworld in which mazes
represent an inward journey toward an
awakening into consciousness cobb
explains to ariadne how dream sharing
works the diagram of the cycle of
creation versus perception in our mind
and how they get in between that process
visualized with a line extending this
filmmaking metaphor the line is like a
movie screen a literal projection of a
simulated reality for the mind to
perceive and cobb underlines this point
never really remember the beginning of a
dream do you you always wind up right in
the middle of what's going on similarly
film scenes begin in the middle of the
action or the greek term in medias race
ariana's awareness shatters a dream and
cinematographer wally feister used six
high-speed cameras to capture the
exploding debris at a thousand frames
per second they also use vfx to help
accentuate all the debris and notice
this piece of paper as it gets pushed by
the geysers of the street as if it was
under water similar to the water
collapsing cob stream earlier ariade now
sees it's in slow motion because she's
still in the dream and now it explodes
to the speed of reality above which is
slower from her point of view above
arthur explains that's why the military
developed dream sharing it was a
training program for soldiers to shoot
and stab and strangle each other and
wake up ah so here nolan sticks to his
insistence of real world practicality
like he used in the dark knight trilogy
like all of batman's technology no
fantasy tech exists just because they're
all justified in things like military
research they go back in the dream and
ariane folds paris on top of itself
creating this impossible architecture
inspired by m.c escher whom ariane also
references by using escher's druste
effect to create that bridge one reason
the visuals are so eye-popping was the
effort that the vfx artists put into the
geometry of shadows the surreal angles
of the bending skyline feel more vivid
to us because of the perfect timing of
the shadow lines that spill over the
facades really proper lighting is the
key to good vfx arthur shows ariane has
totem which is a loaded die which always
lands on the number five similarly
arthur is the fifth member of the team
in terms of how deep they all go like
yusuf is the outermost dreamer at number
six arthur at number five and so on and
so on and when the hotel rolls arthur
tumbles like this loaded die does but he
always keeps his center of gravity this
whole totem character parallel also
applies to eems tom hardy the forger of
this team it's implied his totem is his
poker chip you see him flipping around
on his fingers a lot the flaw of his
totem is that he misspelled mombasa with
two s's characterizing eems as a risk
taker and a mimic and he bets on unlucky
number 13 because he thrives under chaos
in this filmmaking metaphor eames is the
actor of the group the big ego smartass
but also the one with the sharpest
understanding of human psychology it's
eames who unpacks fisher's complex daddy
issues the way great actors can
invigorate and find the truth of
otherwise hollow scenes and use props to
great effect hardy described eames as a
james bond wannabe which is why he's
first seen gambling and on his dream
level he reenacts on her majesty's
secret service cobb has chased through
mombasa by sado's rivals and notice how
this scene supposedly said in reality
doesn't all function realistically men
tackle cobb from out of nowhere an
overhead shot makes the alleys look like
a maze the walls literally close in on
cobb the way dreams can often feel
claustrophobic sato randomly shows up in
a cartoonishly convenient moment at one
point one guy even tells cobb i'm not
dreaming now i am blue this whole foot
chase parallels the foot chase of the
matrix neo running from the agents in a
simulated reality as we'll find out
later nolan deliberately made this over
the top to further blur the distinction
between dreams and reality meanwhile
another mcesha reference comes up with
the penrose stairs an example of a
paradox that arthur uses to teach
ariadne how to use impossible
architecture to create closed loops
arthur will actually use this exact
design later in his dream level and the
movie's best call back paradox
[Music]
and while the team recruits their
chemist yusuf philippe real yusuf is
actually the arabic form of joseph who
was a dream interpreter from the book of
genesis completing this filmmaking team
metaphor yusuf is a technician like the
director photography a lighting director
a vfx artist the one who applies science
to produce the most vivid imagery and
the widest bandwidth within which the
rest of the team operates yusuf shows
them how his custom-made sedative is
used in the sleep chamber they come here
every day to sleep
no
they come to be woken up
the dream has become the reality who are
you to say otherwise so this man is
invoking the existential crisis at the
heart of this film and at the heart of
the matrix what is reality philosopher
renee descartes explored this in his
famous dream argument arguing that it's
possible that we can wake up but still
be dreaming so we cannot trust our
senses and perceptions this concept is
also referred to as the zhuangzi paradox
really the matrix and inception led a
generation of basic nerds to assume
we've been red pilled sato briefs them
on the mark robert fisher killian murphy
who represents the audience in this
filmmaking metaphor he's the heir to an
australian-owned business empire which
sato wants fisher to dissolve nolan and
murphy based this family dynamic on
rupert murdoch and his fraught
relationships with his sons
interestingly enough murdock's empire is
starting to break up right now with
disney's recent buy out of fox huh
iam spies on the fisher inner circle
noticing the pinwheel photo that robert
placed beside his father in that picture
killian murphy actually doubled for a
young maurice fisher with glasses and a
mustache so eems is following a key
process of an actor observation note
that this is the one scene in the movie
that the real browning appears from here
on after every time we see him he's
actually being impersonated by eames or
he's projected by robert based on eem's
caricature it's a reminder that fisher's
whole narrative and catharsis in this
movie was invented on the spot and
carried out by the actor of the group so
it's easy for producers like arthur to
see actors as replaceable but it's
actors who bring all the humanity and
soul to the narrative the full team
gathers to strategize and summon pointed
out that if you take the first letters
the main character's names dom robert
eames arthur maul and sado you get
dreams but that leaves out aryane and
yusuf who are pretty important too so if
you add peter ariadne and yusuf you get
dreams pay you know what they also spell
out dramas yup because anagrams are
random and stupid they're brainstorming
here of how to trigger catharsis in
fisher mirrors a hollywood writer's room
trying to break a story and as we'll see
each layer of the dream is a different
cinematic theme based on three of
nolan's biggest influences as mentioned
before the bottom layer instream is a
snow fortress with an elaborate ski
shootout and homage to one of nolan's
favorite 07 movies on her majesty's
secret service but the next layer up
arthur's dream is a hotel maze like the
labyrinthian overlook hotel in stanley
kubrick's shining actually a shot of
cobb and fisher in the hotel bathroom is
framed a match kubrick shot of jack and
grady in the bathroom and this hotel
later rotates 360 degrees on a practical
custom-built set with nolan citing the
rotating set of kubrick's 2001 a space
odyssey is inspiration the top layer
yusuf stream is set in downtown los
angeles which devolves into a deadly
machine gun shootout inspired by michael
mann's heat which nolan used as a basis
for his story in the dark knight and
you'll notice that several of the
group's brainstorming sessions take
place in these dream levels not just to
show us these like empty movie sets
before shooting begins but also when you
think about it to give this team more
time to think through their plan ariane
sneaks into one of cobb's late night
dream sessions finding that he can only
dream by revisiting memories maul's
childhood bedroom their first house
together the beach with the family the
train yard their house when they had
kids and maul's hotel suite where she
died all of these locations show up
later in the movie when cobb takes
ariana through limbo which was
constructed from his and maul's memories
with all their favorite locations in a
neat little row now cobb has
reconstructed his limbo in a column that
he revisits every night where he tries
to keep maul buried on the airplane the
flight attendant is played by miranda
nolan chris nolan's cousin and daughter
of john nolan whom chris cast and batman
begins in the dark knight rises and they
descend to the first dream level
drenched in rain because yusuf's full
bladder notice that when arthur drives a
taxi he turns off this arabic music from
the radio the song is a boon saloon by
yusuf el majad which likely would have
been a song that this yusef whose dream
this is chose so in addition to the 2053
and 3502 numbers that i mentioned before
the license plates on all these cars has
a state motto reading the alternate
state so after a shootout in a chase
cyto gets hit and they realize a major
communication error arthur didn't report
that fischer's subconscious would be
militarized and cobb didn't report that
their heavy sedation would drop them
into limbo if they die so yes the rules
do change in this moment here but it's
also in a way that raises the stakes and
make things a lot harder for the heroes
so this isn't like convenient bad
writing every heist movie features this
kind of mid-heist crisis that changes
the game and make things harder eames
transforms into browning using an
actor's vanity mirror and one by one the
reflections change into browning every
time it cuts back to him with eems
reflecting little pieces of browning's
nature but not until he screams do we
objectively see him in browning form
because that scream is heard by fisher
who recognizes it as his uncle and thus
from here forward we see him in
character cobb tells ariane about limbo
with flashbacks showing him with maul
using sand castles that they collapse
and in the background they crumble as
well we learned that they spent
something like 50 years together but to
get maul to leave this world cop broke
into her safe decided to spin her top
totem accepting the concept of this
world isn't real in her mind which
worked in the short term to get her out
of limbo but it worked too well and
ended up defining her so that she would
question every reality that she was in
until she killed herself framing cobb
for murder hoping that he would join her
so they pressure fischer for a random
six-digit safe combination and he just
blurts out 528-491
totally random number that they use as a
macguffin in this sub-narrative a
seemingly all-too-important detail that
really only serves to drive the hero
fisher in this sub-narrative to his
deeper realization in level two they
reinforced this number for fisher the
phone number on the napkin and the hotel
room numbers so that in level three when
he opens the safe with this code he
feels like he unlocked a puzzle feeling
a self-accomplishment that was actually
all manufactured to drive him toward his
emotional catharsis which again is what
movies do folks sorry your emotional
breakthrough while watching toy story
was designed for you all of your tears
have andy stamped on them so down in
level two the hotel eems poses as a
blonde woman to flirt with fisher a nod
to the woman in the red dress from the
matrix which is also a trick designed as
a distraction as cobb runs the mr
charles gambit on fisher turning him
against his own subconscious he freezes
up when he hears the glass breaking he
sees his kids playing nearby the glass
break is the same sound from him
stepping on the glass back in the suite
and it represents maul breaking into his
operation just as she did with the train
so on the first two levels maul's
interference takes the form of tragic
memories for cobb setting her up to make
one final catastrophic interference in
person on the third level after leading
fischer to believe browning was working
against him they established a secret
about his father that fisher is
naturally desperate to know so they say
they're going into browning's dream but
in reality it's eames dream the snow
fortress up above eustis crazy driving
sets up some really fun physics for
arthur to tumble around in like a
producer on any number of troubled film
productions arthur is left alone to
thanklessly wrestle with problem after
problem and when yusuf drives off the
cliff early and they miss the first kick
arthur has to quickly and ingeniously
apply newtonian physics to kick them all
without gravity that's a great producer
ariane sharing eem's shortcut to the
hospital allows cobb and the small to
also know it so fischer gets shot and
drops in a limbo along with sado ariana
and cobb dropped down to retrieve them
now limbo was designed by visual effects
supervisor paul franklin to resemble a
massive glacier made up of stacked
modernist architecture with chunks of it
breaking off into the sea like icebergs
cobb finds them all in their old house
and they have one of the most important
exchanges of the film i know it's real
mo no creeping doubts
not feeling persecuted dumb
chased around the globe by anonymous
corporations and police forces
where the projections persecute the
dreamer with this line nolan is
acknowledging the cliche and convenience
of moments like the mombasa chase
small's right they don't make sense
cobb's reality is as stylized and
cinematic as his michael mann stanley
kubrick and double-oh-seven dream
narratives were and then maul delivers
the ultimate theme of inception you
don't believe in one reality anymore
so choose nolan is suggesting that the
human mind cannot rely on external
objectivity to determine our realities
but we can choose what world we want to
live in truth doesn't come from the
walls around you it comes from a loved
one in your arms inception itself is an
illusory magic trick we think it's about
fisher's catharsis with his father but
that catharsis is just manufactured
bullsh cobb confronting his demon maul
is the true catharsis of inception he
apologizes for corrupting her and he
lets her go because her ghost is merely
his pathetic shade of his true soul mate
kind of like homer simpson's plant
version of march
for his guild cobb sentences himself to
what could be another lifetime in limbo
seriously he and sado grow pretty old
down there it could be another 50 years
or longer we'll never know ariane kicks
fisher back up to the hospital level and
he plays right into the constructed
catharsis with his father that aim set
up for him all from the photo the stupid
pinwheel the daddy issues the word
disappointed things that he learned on
the first dream level so that fisher
will synthesize a new truth i know you
were disappointed
i couldn't be you
no no
i was disappointed
that she tries so they ride the kicks up
and cobb washes up on the beach full
circle to film's prologue which now in
this moment to us feels like a forgotten
dream that drifts into familiarity just
as a dub for cobb and sato who repeat
their promises to each other and just
like the sudden dream like edit before
it happens again and cobb wakes up but
this awakening is the true awakening an
inception for cobb who was once defined
by his fear of the uncertainty of his
reality and now defined by control over
the reality that he chooses to live in
the knowing looks between characters in
these final minutes echoes the ending of
the wizard of oz in which the hero sees
that her friends have reverted from
their fantastical forms to their real
faces and left wondering about the
difference between dream and reality and
that brings us to the famous closing
shot of this film cobb comes home he
spins his totem in disbelief but then he
finally lets himself look at his kid's
faces and he embraces them the camera
focuses on the top which continues to
spin and spin and spin and then
[Music]
yeah it's a deliberately ambiguous
ending a tease meant to leave us forever
in doubt of course if you look into it
there is plenty of evidence that cobb's
world is indeed real now the top does
wobble about to fall over cobb is not
wearing his wedding ring and michael
caine said that nolan told him that
whenever his character is in the scene
it means it's real but this debate
doesn't matter because the final shot of
the top is another misdirect by nolan
leading her eye to an intriguing
distraction while allowing the deeper
catharsis that he incepted in our minds
to settle the secret truth of this
moment is that cobb isn't looking at the
top he only cares about his kids and if
you follow his attention and pay
attention to the reality that cobb has
chosen his son james actually says
something amazing when cobb asks them
what they were up to
[Music]
a house on a cliff limbo yeah you could
argue that it doesn't totally make sense
for cobb to have woken up straight from
limbo to the airplane and for a man
wanted for murder to miraculously make
it through security just off of a phone
call so sure cobb could still be
dreaming and maul was right this movie
had bizarre dreamlike elements and
descartes and zhuangzi were right our
whole lives could be a dream that we
haven't yet woken up from but is that
any way to live the incepted truth that
cobb learned from maul and perhaps that
christopher nolan realized himself as
the cob-like visionary of this dream
within a film within a dream and the
truth that we take away from it is that
we determine our realities and that
reality can be as simple as a loving
embrace really isn't that the dream you
never want to wake up from now the dream
i never want to wake up from is the one
where me and thor team up to beat up my
ninth grade bully in front of his
weeping children do you think cobb is
still dreaming hop down in the comments
and let me have it i want to know your
take on this and let me know what film
you'd like to see me break down next in
the series follow me on instagram and
twitter eavos subscribe to new rockstars
and thank you for joining me in this
wonderful breakdown of inception a movie
i literally got a job at a movie theater
in the summer of 2010 so that i could
watch it over and over again ah now
those are great times
let me remember that
[Music]
you